les presento a una parte de la gráfica
que es igual a x cuadrada y lo que vamos
a usar es nuestros poderes que tenemos
de integral definida para encontrar los
valores del área bajo la curva así que
recordemos qué va a pasar cuando
nosotros tomábamos la expresión de la
integral definida de 0 a 2 de x cuadrada
de x que es lo que representaba entonces
vamos a buscar estos puntos x igual a 0
es este de aquí y vamos a suponer que
este que estoy dibujando es x igual a 2
y bueno lo que hacíamos es que para cada
x encontrábamos un pequeño de x
alrededor de ella este de aquí es
nuestro pequeño de x y bueno a este de x
lo multiplicamos por nuestra función es
decir por x cuadrada por lo tanto lo que
nos fijábamos era en este rectángulo de
aquí y sacábamos su área lo único que
estamos haciendo es multiplicando la
base que es de x por la altura que es la
función en este caso x cuadrado y bueno
al final lo que decíamos es que la
integral definida dada por la expresión
que tenemos aquí arriba tomábamos
la suma de todos estos rectángulos para
todo el eje x en el intervalo de 0 a 2 y
después si se acuerdan lo que hacíamos
era tomar el límite de estos rectángulos
cuando de x se sea muy muy muy pequeño
tan pequeño que decíamos que era
infinitamente pequeño casi casi cercano
a cero y eso nos daba la idea de poder
decir que íbamos a tomar la suma de
todos estos rectángulos pequeños
entonces pues ya te puedes imaginar que
si nosotros hacemos a de x pequeño
pequeño pequeño entonces estos
rectángulos se vuelven delgados delgados
delgados y por lo tanto tenemos una
mejor mejor mejor aproximación una mejor
aproximación del área bajo la curva que
estamos buscando ahora lo que quiero en
este vídeo no es mostrarles el área bajo
la curva sino lo que voy a querer es
rodar esta función alrededor del eje de
las equis y para esto voy a necesitar
todos tus poderes de visualización para
que nosotros entendamos qué es lo que
está sucediendo bueno pues nosotros
giramos esta función alrededor del eje
de las x entonces va a tener una base
muy parecida a ésta
imagínate la y bueno también tengo que
dibujar la función pero en esta ocasión
hacia abajo y ya lo tenemos aquí esto es
muy parecido al chocolate 15 es tal vez
oa las piezas que tenemos en algunos
juegos de mesa o tal vez algún tipo de
gorro extraño o algo así como los gorros
de fiesta pero aplastados y bueno ahora
le voy a dar un poco de volumen esto ya
le da más proporción y la verdad estoy
intentando que mi dibujo me quede lo
mejor posible para que tú me entiendas y
visualices qué es lo que está pasando me
tienes que echar porras para que tú lo
veas muy bien voy a intentar dibujarlo
en varios ángulos así que vamos a
dibujar otro tipo de ángulo y para que
sea mucho más obvio que si se ve como un
sombrero imagínate qué bueno esta es la
base del sombrero y todo esto es el
cuerpo del sombrero y si lo viéramos
desde esta perspectiva no podríamos ver
la parte de atrás pero tenemos la parte
de enfrente y bueno si lo que quieres es
orientarte un poco acerca de dónde
estamos parados en esta función pues
este va a ser nuestro eje de las 10
y entonces este otro el que está adentro
del sombrero es el eje de las equis para
que no te pierdas
imagínate que este sombrero es
transparente y si fuera transparente
entonces esta sería la parte de atrás de
este sombrero y bueno si fuera
transparente entonces podríamos ver que
la base se intersecta tarde o temprano
con el eje de las x aquí y perfecto ya
tenemos otra perspectiva de este mismo
sombrero ya lo puedes ver desde dos
tipos de perspectivas distintas la
pregunta importante de este vídeo es
cómo encontramos el volumen de este
sombrero para esto me voy a basar
también en la idea de los rectángulos
pero en esta ocasión en lugar de fijarme
en lugar de pensar en el área bajo la
curva voy a pensar que sus rectángulos
lo que van a hacer es girar también
alrededor del eje de las x que es lo que
nos quedaría si esto pasa pues no nos
queda más que hacerlo entonces a ver
tomemos a uno de esos rectángulos
supongamos que tenemos a este de x que
tengo aquí y lo que voy a hacer es girar
lo alrededor del eje de las equis y con
esto me va a quedar un tipo de moneda
o un tipo de disco de hecho se llaman
discos
aquí en nuestro dibujo me quedaría algo
así y bueno este disco tiene un grosor
de de x ahora la pregunta correcta es
cómo vamos a encontrar el volumen de
este disco y bueno para esto déjame
dibujarte lo aquí es muy importante que
siempre estemos trabajando con la
visualización este de aquí va a ser mi
disco se va a ver más o menos así está
que estoy dibujando es la cara de este
disco este es su centro y lo último que
estoy dibujando es su grosor
su grosor que es de x y bueno para sacar
el área de este disco lo que voy a
pensar es en sacar el área de un
cilindro porque este disco al final es
un cilindro y si tú recuerdas cómo sacar
el volumen de un prisma me vas a decir
que es el grosor por el área de la cara
ahora la pregunta es cómo sacamos el
área de esta cara que yo tengo aquí
bueno pues es el área de un círculo muy
bien y como sacamos el área de un
círculo bueno el área de un círculo es
pi por radio al cuadrado ahora
pregunte quién es el radio de este
círculo o de este disco
pero el radio de este disco no es ni más
ni menos que quien que la función porque
era el alto del rectángulo es decir el
radio es la función que nosotros tenemos
que en este caso es x cuadrado y
entonces ya podemos sacar la fórmula del
área el área es igual a pi por el radio
en paréntesis al cuadrado pero el radio
es x cuadrada por lo tanto me queda pi
por equis cuadrada elevado al cuadrado
ahora ya tenemos el área de esta
superficie pero como dijimos que íbamos
a sacar el volumen de este disco pues
claro multiplicando esta área por de x
porque de x es el ancho de esta moneda
de este disco por lo tanto el volumen de
este disco que yo tengo aquí va a ser
igual entonces a quien el volumen
entonces va a ser igual al área que ya
saqué que multiplica al ancho pero el
ancho es d
el grosor y bueno como ya sabemos la
función del área entonces esto es lo
mismo que pi por equis elevado al
cuadrado al cuadrado que es x elevado a
la cuarta por de x
por x elevado a la cuarta por de x ahora
bien
date cuenta que esta expresión que
tenemos aquí nos da el volumen de uno de
estos discos de solamente una de estas
monedas pero nosotros lo que vamos a
querer es el área de este gorro entero
de este sombrero entero o de esta
trompeta es como un final de una
trompeta y bueno como vamos a sacar
entonces el volumen de este sombrero de
esta trompeta pues la idea es la misma
la misma idea para sacar el área bajo la
curva lo que voy a hacer es tomarme la
suma infinita de todos estos volúmenes
es decir me voy a tomar la integral la
integral de pi que multiplica a x
elevado a la cuarta diferencial de x lo
que estoy haciendo es tomando la suma de
todos estos volúmenes y bueno de dónde a
dónde
x 0 a x igual a 2 y bueno lo que vamos a
querer es el límite cuando te x hace muy
muy pequeño es decir lo que estoy
buscando es que estos volúmenes se hagan
más y más estrechos y en el límite voy a
encontrar por fin el volumen de este
gorro así que si lo que tenemos que
hacer es resolver esta integral pues
vamos a hacerlo
cuál es la integral de 0 a2dp x cuarta
de x bueno el pi sale porque es una
constante y me queda la integral de 0 a
2 de x 4a de x pero esta integral es muy
fácil resolverla pues su anti derivada
es x quinta entre 5 le sumamos 1 al
exponente y lo dividimos entre ese mismo
número y esto evaluado de 0 a 2 por lo
tanto vamos a hacerlo me queda pi que
multiplica a 2 elevado a la quinta entre
5 recuerden que primero sustituyó el
valor que está arriba 2 elevado las 5
entre 5 - la evaluación en el punto de
abajo es decir 0 a la quinta entre 5 2 a
la quinta es lo mismo que 32 entonces me
va a quedar pi que multiplica a treinta
y dos quintos primero
pues 000 entonces me queda simple y
sencillamente cero y entonces ya obtuve
el resultado el resultado del volumen de
esta trompeta es 32 pi entre 5 y con
esto encuentro el volumen de este gorro